the Joe Rogan experience I've never gone
down on a girl although it is kind of on
my bucket list it's on your box I want
to be able to say I've done it it's not
something I crave but I'm going to do it
at some point in my life
good luck ladies whoever you are I have
my eye on a couple yeah I'm happy no uh
yeah it's weird cuz I like do you not
have like a male gaze do you what do you
mean like you have your eye on them the
guy has his eye on a girl could be
creepy if the girl's not into it like oh
Jesus here comes this oh right oh here
comes Nikki trying to eat my [ __ ] again
I test the waters and I'm like have you
ever like done anything with a girl cuz
I've never even done anything with a
girl so I mean I made out with my
girlfriends in high school but that was
before I even kissed a boy and I just
wanted to kiss I just want to try it
yeah but since then never fooled around
with a girl but there's some that I'm
just like I can't help that I'm I'm
attract a not I don't consider myself
gay but I'm on the spectrum somewhere
I'm on then I could do it and recently
I've been like yeah I need to I need to
need to get in there eat some puss
woo because I've never done it and I
expect men to do it to me right I think
I should understand what it's like and
and be able to empathize and no guy
thinks that is straight about sorry yeah
I know I know
mmm maybe I should suck a couple dick so
I can just cuz you could see what that's
like just tastes just lick your own
finger if you get some come on it just
to experience it yeah maybe maybe but
what else is on your bucket list
um I think that's it and I really hope
that I get this accomplished before I'm
like dying and like 88 or something in
my grandkids have to like find a nurse
to squat over my [ __ ] bed like one
thing or like you're old and rich and
successful some lady does not want you
eat ur [ __ ] but she does want a Gucci
bag I'll definitely be able to buy that
[ __ ] a Gucci bag my face will look like
one at that point yeah bucket list do
you have any bucket list things
no no no you've already done them all
yeah I don't have anything everything
I'm doing I like to keep doing I would
like to be in a
I would like to be in loved and loved
back as much as I love I would like to
be in a loving relationship at some
point it doesn't have to last forever
but I I know that sounds like it was
good yeah
and I don't think it's it might not
happen and I'm okay with that why
wouldn't it happen you're young
whoa all right you could I could totally
die young yeah we get all that we can
all get hit in the head by a meteor
right now no more do something good at
the an earthquake like yeah and then I
would die without having a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my mouth or love in my heart loving
you could ever be in a relationship with
a woman
yeah probably really yeah I mean I
really want a relationship with amazed
erst usually takes around with a dog
collar on your neck I mean I don't want
to be a sex slave I only in the bedroom
do I would have I don't want to be one
out and about not sexy but in the
bedroom yeah I'm down to be forgetten
slave does this woman wrote me recently
because she knows that I'm into like
bondage and stuff like that I saw that
on your Instagram yeah yeah I it truly
is
I mean I I like it because it is forced
laziness like I say in my joke like it
you can't do anything to a guy like and
by the way it's not that they don't like
doing things to men it's just that I
feel like I'm not good at a lot of those
things I've bad rhythm so like jerking
guys or like sucking dick I just I'd
rather you do it to me sucking dick
makes sense is really hard for a guy to
suck his own dick but jerking off I just
have a joke about it like having a girl
jerk your office like trying to brush
your teeth with your left hand hilarious
no matter what it's like you can't do it
right yes if you ever try to brush your
teeth my right hand knows where
everything so trail my right hand just
[ __ ] go
yeah it knows my left hand I can I got
to move my head to keep up with my yes
that's why I like when guys grab my head
and just like take take take though take
the wheel take though we don't know what
you want hmm
but I'm getting better at it but I'm
trying I've had to like give some
[ __ ] just out of like I need to
practice when a girl can jerk you off of
a girl jerked you off she's really good
at you like Jesus how many guys you jerk
we can't win can we he'll no you can't
no no you can't win you just go now
really good thank you for acknowledging
it no hand jobs I just love well I feel
like fingering to like girls probably
were like way better at finger no get in
there
I love being fingered got in the best I
love it
no difference in girls and guys girls
have smaller hands like thick fingers
like a Mason good guy who is a
bricklayer get them up there I don't
know man get them all up there I don't
mind it
[Applause]